alors moi qui ai fait de la filda non je
vous ai pas dans la forme mais tant pis
pour des lois dessinent
problème est ce que c'est ça qu'a c'est
ça qui est derrière ces importance et
les libertés des gens c'est délibéré
vous rue molière de noter qu'aucun
citoyen moi je suis une en une union une
enfant de rousseau du contrat social de
rousseau
sociale à la voilà avec un pass
vaccinale est un qr code qui dira oui
toi tu as le droit de faire ça tu es un
bon citoyen toi tu n'as pas loin de
faire pas être refusé par un bon citoyen
du provisoire à moi je ne veux pas que
mes enfants chevaux sont là qui se
retrouve comme en chine plus qu'avec
avec eux des scaphandres sur la tronche
ou avec des gens qu'on humilie je ne
veux pas que mes enfants soient comme en
australie qu on les arrache de leurs
parents pour les vacciner de fortes je
ne veux pas que comme à rotterdam on a
tiré à balles réelles sur des
manifestants
parce que ça vous ne leur est volée ou
alors vos enfants puisqu'on le fait
partout 1-1 pas parce qu'on le fait
partout warner ses filles sasha waltz
j'ai quand même globalement donc chacun
fait ce qu'il veut même
par delà
les lois sont débiles quand on vous dit
qu'il fois font manger debout dans un
restaurant alors qu'on sait cinq chutes
s'imposer dans un restaurant alors qu'on
sait aujourd'hui qu'en étant vacciner on
peut contaminer les gens et on est
soi-même contagieux la preuve vous avez
été vaccinées vous avez choper le covin
la symptomatiquement voilà d'accord et
pas très bien aimé mais c'est juste
aberrant bonjour virage à 90 % des gens
y compris les politiques sont débiles et
ya toi qui a vu que c'était pas débile
si vous vous serez alors je vous invite
à regarder les débats à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat il y a énormément
de sénateurs qui s'offusquent de tout ça
mais comme ils sont minoritaires je vous
rappellerai juste où il ya plein d'amis
j'ai bien bougé nouvelle ré sur le mois
comme ça je rappellerai juste quand même
que le pack vaccinale quand il a été
voté la première fois il a été refusée à
16 heures il ya eu des petits
arrangements avec le modem et ils ont
repassé à plus d'une heure du matin
quand il n'y avait plus de députés dans
la dans l'assemblée et rajouter du verre
sanitaires chez les sanitaires pas
obligés à l'assemblée nationale par
exactement je suis extrêmement choqué
par ce qu a dit géraldine ce qu'on dit
géraldine et ses deux portes flingues
[Applaudissements]
au fait est grave c'est tout simplement
du mépris de classe ah oui c'est à dire
que vous estimez
n'ai pas dit ni rien de vous qu'elle ne
pas s opposer des arguments mais laissez
moi je
signale analystes
justifient leur longe et cink et des
lois qui sont votées par un remariage
blessés de part et ont déjà rien dire
c'est chiant je trouve que c'est ça la
réponse est ce si amandine et en faisant
ça et en faisant ça il ya des millions
de gens qui vont milliards à les liens
lâché pouvoir est un peu de leur mort
c'est vrai beaucoup de saga arriver ici
a désormais sa gamme plus rien well
semblant de m'intéresser à toi
mais c'est pas bien parce qu'il ya
anglais mme abileah vous foutent de ce
fait que vous allez faire se radicaliser
installé dans les manifestations être
épuisé être sur les nerfs vous ne les
écoutez pas écouté myriam et les
discordances de vous j'ai peut-être que
sa voix pour autant claveau nue donc
stoppée avec vos mimines briller votre
condescendance voire juste et aya
guillaume fait d'accord une mousse non
pas bien sûr nommé en fait j'écoute
matures en fait tu veux que l'émission
ici ressemble à quoi tu veux que cyril
lisent les mesures du gouvernement et
que tout le monde applaudit sans écouter
écouter une émission cotchery guillaume
dsk dit géraldine c'est quand je suis
malade j'appelle plutôt un médecin que
l'accessoire